pour Spinoza ce n'est jamais le corps
seul ou l'esprit seul qui est affecté
c'est l'unité corps esprit qui est
affecté dans son ensemble vous vous
cassez une jambe ça va vous démoraliser
cause physique effet psychique un ami
vous a trahi la colère envahit votre
corps cause psychique effet physique on
est dans ce que Spinoza appelle les
affects de tristesse vous vous prélassez
sur un transat au bord de la mer votre
esprit est détendu cause physique effet
psychique vous venez d'apprendre que
vous attendez un enfant
votre corps exulte
cause psychique effet physique
on est dans ce que Spinoza appelle les
affects de joie